[Music]
good lord you look fantastic
you think so thank you yeah thank you
very much yeah yeah you do too Oh we
mean is that fishing for compliments uh
what do you mean well you look fantastic
and I happen to have seen that Chelsea
Handler bit that you did in the shower
naked EW that people that got around a
little bit
some people saw it there look at that
fantastic did you see his abs in that
how have you achieved that because I
happen to know by the way if you're
doing that you're turning 50 years old
tomorrow yes tomorrow and you've got a
six pack or a 12 pack or something
you've got that it's an 18 pack well
congratulate it's unheard of how would
you know what I I don't know I I go to
the gym a lot and you see me in the gym
don't I see him at the gym well come on
no to my six-pack is insulated to keep
it holy
so you're saying you know I'm offended
by a little bit as people are surprised
that's what I'm offended I wasn't
surprised yes you were yo
oh you're very cool no you look every
bit a leading man as you stand there and
in your head area you look you look
handsome and like you would have a
six-pack or an 18 pack or what you can
tell by looking at my head area that I
would have a six-pack yeah we just found
out he's an alien
you're handsome in your head area no you
are talking like someone from another
planet in my phraseology yeah it's it
can be on look at you what that's okay I
think we're that's okay it's okay I
think when a man looks at another man
and says oh that's an attractive man I
think that's fine you do yeah
oh I do too Oh joke on my halls cough
drop there is this is the weirdest
interview
[Applause]
why did you come out here eating candy I
don't nobody does that
you really did just almost choke see if
you can find that footage this is gonna
be all over the internet tomorrow show
that's gonna go viral that's gonna go
butt
[Applause]
say what well the fact that you how
inactive is nothing where was his heroic
launching into a Heimlich maneuver and
ease in the Heimlich position and did
nothing nothing how far would I've
gotten before you would have you know I
don't know we just bring the next guest
down I would have said when you got the
same shade as your shirt then I would
have I'm sorry are you okay
yeah the way you say it is like
perfunctory not really uh sincerely okay
no I like you a lot
you've been coming on as a guest for
years you which establishes an
attraction and so I'm sorry you almost
died seconds ago if you decided to munch
some candy out here drink that was that
was inappropriate I'm sorry I apologize
for that
yeah way but it was a halls it was a
halls and I thought that being a little
um mentholated would give me some vocal
warmth and a nice a nice you know you
want everything everything
[Applause]
you're getting you're getting money from
the hole weren't you
for obvious but I did almost Ricky a
whole
their allah one has many mentholated
holes one has many laws and choices and
there are many good ones Fisherman's
Friend is nice very strong work in both
sides of the street now a I have no I
have no skin in the game you know what I
mean by that what are you doing you just
took your watch off for no reason and
you're playing with it it's not as odd
as you would make out you do is odd and
unusual you're talking to me you choke
on a lozenge weird mid-conversation and
then you start taking your watch off
dangling it around you know what if I
did that you know just talking this is
normal yes yes what I did was was
equivalent to that right I think you're
exaggerating mister okay good exam